Speaker 1: Dave Rubin is a former leftist,
I guess, who now voted Trump, and I guess
is like kind of friends with Don Jr. and Dave
Rubin known to some of you as, you know, a
cultural critic or an arbiter of ideas. He
said yesterday or the day before that the
unvaccinated are now being treated like the
Jews right before the Holocaust, except that
there aren't yet gas chambers, and he's referring
to the protests in Canada and the truckers
and this entire thing. Now there are people
who are going to say, Wow, Dave Rubin is Jewish,
so we should be listening to what he says
about the Holocaust because he's, you know,
what he's saying is just wrong, and we should
be critically analyzing what he says. And
let's take a look at the video clip and this
this is exact. Again, it's the same reactionary
kind of fear porn that we talked about just
minutes ago.
Speaker 3: I just said to my guys, as we were
playing this, it's truly incredible watching
these people flip the story and how they reverse
everything they say about one thing. When
it's their guys doing it versus how they say
it, when it's the other guy's doing it. First
off, I just want to say something very, very
clearly, please. I lost family members on
both sides of the Holocaust. OK, I grew up
around Holocaust survivors.
Speaker 1: Now you guys understand this. This
is, in a sense, identity politics. I don't
want to belabor this point, but I don't want
to miss it. They love to say identity politics
is toxic. Any time anyone says, as a woman
of color, I believe, or as you know, as as
a as a trans black person, I believe they
say that's terrible. That's identity politics.
Ruben is doing it here. He's about to give
us his view that the unvaccinated are being
treated like Jews before the Holocaust, and
he tells us I lost family in the Holocaust.
He's he's playing identity politics, he's
using his identity to make us believe that
he is more trustworthy in his opinion, when
they decry that very mechanism, when they
perceive the left is doing it. Do not miss
this key point. They're against identity politics,
except when they do it.
Speaker 3: I'm well-versed in what the Holocaust
was and what the demonization. There you go,
people, is although the guy who is interviewed
there and by the way, great cherry picking
on that daily show. And then they they cherry
pick that on The Daily Show. And then of course,
they throw that to CNN because they're all
in on it together. I believe they're both
owned by Viacom. It's just one big circle
jerk.
Speaker 1: So there's big conspiracy there,
of course.
Speaker 3: And just regardless of what the
guy said, whether you think he said it in
a butchered way or he shouldn't say it or
something like that, the way something like
the Holocaust starts is you otherize people,
right? You keep otherize other rising them.
You say, Oh, you can't be part of the economy,
you can't own a store, you can't do this.
We're going to demonize you, your disease.
So it is not a giant leap. OK. It really is
not. And I don't care how much hate I get
for this. It is not a giant leap. After two
years of demonizing certain people who wanted
choice, medical choice and choice used to
be thought of as a good thing to compare them
to the Jews before the Holocaust. It's not
a perfectly symmetrical situation now, right?
There are gas chambers in Canada, yet yet
OK, so it's not perfect.
Speaker 1: There is no analogy to the Holocaust
or the pre Holocaust era in Europe when people
just are told to get vaccinated. First of
all, remember that what he deliberately or
out of ignorance ignores here is that the
Holocaust was based on the reality that Jews
were fundamentally pick. Pick your word right?
Inferior, unclean, disease ridden, demonic,
satanic, whatever. Fundamentally, at a core
level, what's going on with the unvaccinated
is just like, Hey, we think they're making
kind of a dumb choice. There's nothing inherent
about the unvaccinated. It's not by birth
that these are there's there's there's quite
literally no analogy whatsoever. And this
is if you want to play the identity game,
Rubin says. I would know about this because
I'm Jewish. No, this is that much more gross
because you're Jewish. And if you want to
be accurate, the way the Holocaust started
was straight up sort of like racism against
Jews and extreme German nationalism. And of
course, this type of nationalism is much more
prevalent on the right in the United States
than on the left. The last thing on this is
it's always the fear of the slippery slope.
There aren't gas chambers yet, but vaccine
requirements point in that direction. It's
a false, slippery slope. False slippery slopes
are hallmarks of reactionary thinking. Look,
they keep telling us at the back any vaccine
mandates will lead to totalitarianism. But
look at the history of vaccine mandates. In
1777, George Washington made the smallpox
vaccine requirement for soldiers in eighteen
oh nine. Massachusetts put in the first vaccine
mandate in 1855. Massachusetts put it in the
first school vaccine mandate in nineteen oh
five, the US Supreme Court decided in Jacobson
v. Massachusetts, Cambridge. I believe it
is can require vaccines. In 1977, Childhood
Immunization Initiative started requiring
certain vaccines for schools, and it's never
gone further than just sometimes. We require
vaccines. There's no there's no concentration
camps, there's no gas chambers, there's none
of it. So be very skeptical when they use
the idea of this is opening the door up to
x y z. Well, if that's the case, it's been,
you know, more than 200 years since vaccines
were first required in the United States,
and it's not been a slippery slope. So all
of this stuff hallmarks of reactionary thinking.
Understand it. Don't be tricked by it. Find
me on Twitter at David Pakman and let me know
your reaction